driven by the need for answers the crowd
chants outside the headquarters of the
metropolitan police
no justice
it's nearly two weeks since the car
chris kubber was driving was hemmed in
by two police vehicles five miles south
of here in streatham hill and a single
shot fired by an officer through the
windscreen
it was enough to kill him
the car wasn't registered to chris no
firearm was found
his cousin says it's critical the police
are held to account for the death of a
24 year old about to become a father how
do i look his daughter on the eyes when
she grows up and say that you know your
father died
as a result of a police officer shooting
him and we didn't get justice
i don't know how i'm going to justify
justify that to her
that means we have to get justice
at a protest last week the family had
three demands they've all been met
the officer who fired the shot has been
suspended
the family will get to see body cam
footage next week and they now know how
long the investigation is due to take
have been told six to nine months
the independent office for police
conduct describes the investigation as
complex saying there's a significant
amount of evidence to go through some of
which requires expert analysis and that
all takes time
but lawyers for the family are far from
happy describing the time scale as
unacceptably long and lacking in urgency
instead the family wants a decision on
charging to be made within weeks they
also want to find out if police knew it
was chris in the car or were they just
following a suspect vehicle
and the third new demand is for the
suspended officer to be interviewed
under caution i want to know when i will
feel protected by the police rather than
having to be scared of the police not
going to let them brush it under the
carpet we're not going to have another
person who just becomes a statistic a
national call to action resulted in
protests up and down the country
including in manchester
back in london the met police says it
fully supports the investigation which
the iopc has confirmed will consider if
race was a factor
and while that goes on there'll be no
end to the pressure in the quest for
justice
emma birchley sky news central london